Well before the Marvel Cinematic Universe
ruled the world, indie writer/director Kevin
Smith was ahead of the game with his own "View
Askewniverse."
Now, the filmmaker is ready to take us back
there with Jay and Silent Bob Reboot.
If you're wondering what it's all about, we've
got the answers to all your blunt questions.
In keeping with Kevin Smith's indie film roots,
Jay and Silent Bob Reboot will roll out in
a slightly different manner than most major
movies do.
Fathom Events, which distributes special and
live events to select multiplexes, will handle
Reboot's first showings on October 15, 2019.
These special screenings will include an introduction
from Smith, some bonus material, and free
movie posters for lucky fans.
Two days later, Reboot will screen again as
part of a double feature alongside Jay and
Silent Bob Strike Back.
"Jay and Silent Bob only work in small doses,
if at all.
They don't deserve their own movie."
"He's got a point-"
"F--- him.
What's the next one say?"
After those initial events, Smith and Mewes
are taking the show on the road.
The pair will travel around the U.S. to personally
present the film and follow it up with Q&A
sessions.
Between October 21 and December 12, "The Jay
& Silent Bob Reboot Roadshow" will hit 31
cities for 45 screenings.
"So come on out and join us and give us your
money because we gotta eat this year."
Kevin Smith has been doing his own thing in
the movie industry for 25 years.
In that time, he's built up a massive world
of characters within his View Askewniverse,
and Jay and Silent Bob Reboot is bringing
back a ton of them.
Jason Mewes and Kevin Smith are back as the
titular duo, while Jason Lee once again plays
Brodie Bruce, his comics-loving character
from Mallrats.
Joey Lauren Adams will appear as her Chasing
Amy comics creator Alyssa Jones, as will Ben
Affleck, returning as his Chasing Amy character
Holden McNeil.
Affleck's frequent collaborator Matt Damon
will also make an appearance, likely portraying
Loki, his Dogma character, though he's also
appeared in the franchise playing a version
of himself.
"It's hunting season."
Rosario Dawson has signed on to play Becky,
the role she originated in Clerks II, alongside
Brian O'Halloran, returning as Clerks protagonist
Dante.
"I'm not even supposed to be here today!"
It's not all Kevin Smith veterans along for
the ride, though; Val Kilmer, Melissa Benoist,
Joe Manganiello, Justin Long, Craig Robinson,
and Chris Hemsworth are also set to make the
leap into the Askewniverse for the first time.
Yes, Jay and Silent Bob Reboot will revisit
the world of Smith's classic '90s comedies,
just as fans remember them.
It's a self-aware movie, making fun of both
itself and Hollywood's obsession with retreads.
According to Smith, speaking at a post-podcast-taping
Q&A in May 2019, the movie follows what happens
when,
"Jay and Silent Bob find out that Hollywood
is making a reboot of that old movie that
they had made about them [in Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back], and they have to go cross
the country to Hollywood to stop it all over
again."
Smith is well aware of the irony of the situation,
adding the observation,
"It's a movie that makes fun of sequels and
remakes and reboots while being all three
at the same time."
Along with the road trip to stop a movie from
getting made (again), there's a major plot
addition: Jay has a child, a young woman named
Millennium Faulken.
"Millie" is a lot like her father in that
she also has a constant companion who never
speaks, a deaf friend named Soapy.
They insist on heading to Hollywood, too.
On July 18, 2019, movie distributor Saban
Films released the first trailer for Jay and
Silent Bob Reboot.
The profanity-laden preview proves that Reboot
does indeed imitate the plot of Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back, while also making fun of
that movie, and Hollywood, too.
Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back concerns the
duo's trip to Hollywood to shutter a movie
version of Bluntman and Chronic, a marijuana-meets-Batman
style comic book created by Ben Affleck's
character Holden McNeil.
Jason Biggs and James Van Der Beek appear
as themselves as the stars of the adaptation.
Along the way, Jay meets and falls for an
animal rights activist named Justice, played
by Shannon Elizabeth.
According to the Jay and Silent Bob Reboot
trailer, the new movie centers on a reboot
of the Bluntman and Chronic movie in production,
with Val Kilmer and Melissa Benoist taking
on the roles in a winking nod to their other
jobs.
Biggs and Van Der Beek do return for a cameo,
though.
"Who's directing this s--- anyway?
Kevin f---ing Smith?"
Along the way, Jay reconnects with Justice,
who introduces him to their teenage daughter,
played by Harley Quinn Smith, Smith's real-life
daughter.
Jay and Silent Bob diehards can also get a
load of the official Jay and Silent Bob Reboot
poster.
This winking-at-the-past key art is consistent
with the rest of the movie in its nod to the
past, as the poster depicts Jason Mewes and
Kevin Smith in character standing against
a brick wall, not unlike the one they leaned
against in Clerks back in 1994.
Smith also unveiled a movie poster for the
movie-within-a-movie, advertising the Bluntman
and Chronic reboot.
It strikes a dark, gritty tone, reminiscent
of the DC Comics movie starring one of the
View Askewniverse's most successful alumni:
Ben Affleck.
"Affleck was the bomb in Phantoms."
"Word, b----.
Phantoms like a motherf-----."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.